U.S attorney general Merrick Garland
made a surprise trip to Ukraine on
Friday where he reaffirmed the United
States commitment to hold Russia
accountable for war crimes also on
Friday President Biden pledged another
400 million dollar military aid package
for Ukraine and it can't arrive soon
enough as Russia tightens its grip on
the eastern city of bakmut in one of the
bloodiest battles of the war yet MTS
Taya reports now from denipro
the battle for bakmut has for months
being a symbol of Ukraine's ability to
outwit and outgun Russia's military and
mercenary fight but it looks
increasingly likely the besieged city is
at its last stand with the final
remaining residents in the area now
leaving
apartments and worked all my life to buy
it he says but it doesn't exist anymore
if Russian forces are able to capture
buckmut it would be the first major
victory for Moscow in over half a year
tens of thousands of Russian soldiers
are understood to have been killed
trying to secure it and Ukrainian
military leaders also concede defending
the city has resulted in huge losses
losses they don't want to see elsewhere
drills along the northern border with
Belarus follow warnings so Kremlin is
planning to renew defensive this spring
this Maze of trenches was built after
Russian forces crossed over here from
Belarus as part of their failed push
towards Kiev last February if Russian
forces move over this border
are you ready for them
yes this Commander says and we've
prepared a lot of presents for them he
says with a wry smile and the Ukrainian
towns and Villages along the border with
Belarus memories here are still fresh
from the temporary occupation by Russian
troops which withdrew last April after
the Kremlin switched its focus to
Ukraine's Eastern provinces but for
bashlova Tatiana it's a constant fear
are you worried the Russians will come
back
of course we're worried she says we hear
explosions and don't know what it is
we're so scared
so far there's no sign of a major
Russian mobilization on the Northern
front but as the situation continues to
deteriorate in the East Ukrainian forces
aren't taking any chances for CBS
Saturday morning in Fiesta Ukraine